wir machen einfach mal so ein kleines
tutorial kinder games damit jeder auch
wirklich so eine gewisse grundlage hat
jo leute und herzlich willkommen zur
ersten runde des 3 kaspisches zum ersten
teil war heute ein kleines ender games
tutorial weil wir beide als mich gerne
geld spielen ich und mein bruder max
kraft
ich bin übrigens der hässliche machen
oder um die ecke gedacht wir nichts
bekommen alter was das für budget
wir haben uns erwischen wir machen
einfach mal so ein kleines tutorial
schien verändert games damit jeder auch
wirklich so eine gewisse so eine
grundlage hat klar die pros können wir
damit jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht
schocken
die kennen das vielleicht alles schon
aber ich würde mal sagen auch für leute
die zu relativ gut sind gibt vielleicht
noch die eine oder andere sache die man
hier raus noch lernen kann
ja also sind halt relativ basic tipps
also wenn ihr das spiel wirklich kennt
und öfters mal gespielt dann wird
wahrscheinlich ja nicht allzu viel dabei
sein passiert was ihr schon kennt
allerdings er jetzt er eine mango stellt
sich vor mich wenn ich ab heute solche
menschen hast dich ja ich klatschen
jetzt direkt als erste mann der übrigens
an
also es gibt aber zum beispiel um
gespielt hat einen relativ
existenziellen zug von dem spiel kennt
ja zum beispiel aufwändig und letztlich
des todes wichtig und wir sehen uns an
den fakten kennt das nicht
ja ja und zwar ich glaube wenn ich
dieses video richtig gesehen abnehmen
mit den explodierenden nun hat er das
noch nicht ganz raus immer nach dem
kompass läuft also er weiß natürlich
strecken dies das aber es gibt noch
einen tick und zwar ab dass jetzt mal
hier unten links auf die rote nadel die
rote nadel wenn ich mich dreht sich die
nadel mit und zwar die roten rezept
immer in die richtung des nächsten
gegners
ihr müsst nicht nur nach abstand gehen
sondern schaut einfach ok rote nadel in
die richtung also dahin lauf ich so und
ja das macht schon mal ein bisschen
leichter
ja genau also nach kompass laufen ist
der erste track na ja ich habe schon auf
meinen mein zeug hab ich schon mal
schaffen es und ich habe schon mal
scharfes und power auf meinen bogen und
schwert geklatscht und motorstart des
todes gelegt oder ich lag aber ich
glaube er hat gelernt
ich war einfach mal ein holzschwert er
hat auch im schlechten kommen schlechten
film
hank baskett ausgeht
ich habe sehr lieb wieder okay und ich
habe etwas 1 holzspiel und lass mal was
ausprobieren
ich werde ihnen trägt also ich wenn es
geht es richtig lustig schlag jetzt mal
bitte bleib mal einfach gerade stehen
jetzt schlagfertig 81 sogar xxp von
ghost oder excel
das ist so lustig 3000 leute noch ein
dreck für die vorbereitungsphase haben
jetzt gerade nicht demonstrieren können
aber benutzt die schneewälle besonders
in der vorbereitungsphase in einer für
euch an der ändert ist jetzt selbst
folgende also wenn ihr am anfang sind ja
alle leute noch so ziemlich auf einem
haufen und die ersten kisten sind da
immer relativ begehrt und alle leute
rennen darauf zu wenn jetzt aber jemand
vor euch ist und hier in der ersten
kiste schon ein schneeball bekommen habt
also schneverdinger switcher dann werft
am besten den schläger direkt auf den
typen dann werden eure position
sozusagen getauscht und ihr seid vor ihm
an der kiste obwohl er eigentlich als
erster da ja und das ist so ja keinen
trick dahinter und so auf jeden fall
und den kann man gebrauchen wenn man am
anfang sich so ein bisschen den lud
ergaunern will
so ist eher mäßig organ pop shop
ausländer fest da freue ich mich immer
wieder darüber
wir essen und manch ein ziemliches
problem mio und falls ihre probleme hat
essen zu finden dann nehmt das jeder
kennt weiß ich noch nicht
das hat das über alles heute wird ein
symbol ein holzschwert und jo auf diese
mit diesem ende mit diesem jäger geht
könnt ihr wenn ihr mops geld kriegt ihr
dann ich kriegte dann ich glaube so die
doppelte menge an für anlage und die
doppelte menge ist auch noch gebraten
die heißt es ist ultra crazy was dabei
rumkommt
und falls sie jetzt im zufällig prämie
auf dem gomez haben solltet und erstens
probleme habt dann wählt einfach dass
schinken kit aus weil deshalb einen
schinken also einen schon ein ja und der
geht niemals leer und füllt alle ihren
hunger auf also nehme ich mir sorgen
machen
das ist auf jeden fall cool ich habe
auch ganz langer schinken gezockt und
davor jähriger weil ich früher mal die
nahrungs kids genommen bevor ich meine
prämie bekommen bevor ich mir geld
kaufen konnte wegen konz und so und ich
finde dass schinken kit naja es ist
nicht so hammer hat wenn man brutal
schnell hunger punkte verliert aber
wirklich brutal schnell dass es nicht
mehr normal
also man ist immer möglich so schnell du
isst zwei sekunden hast du wieder in
hohenheim hut verloren hat man verliert
schneller hunger viel schneller
das wusste ich überhaupt nicht noch
schneller das also noch schneller als
normal
mal anfassen schwert erste teil hatte
die anderen sind alle richtig gut
ausgerüstet rechts von die sie noch
einige einige kisten roman breaking sehr
wirkungsvolles ich werde aber viel
schlechter verzaubert werden als es das
wert ich hatte schon mehrfach auf dem
schwert mit level 1 versorgung schaffen
und noch keins bekommen habe aber mein
level 1 verzauberung glaube ich
allerdings protection 2 und bauens auf
meine
golfen goldberg what the [ __ ] hast du
wieder in der luft gerettet als er das
gesehen ja der luft hätte wo ist der
achte rennt weg oder wie ich würde
gerade offiziell geträumt im chat kran
kräftig hast du dich ausrufzeichen nicht
80 rechts man jetzt andere 13 auf einem
flecken worte [ __ ] wie es der winter
ausgerüstet
glück gehabt ob wir kassiert gerade vom
anderen eliane 1999 kassiert können muss
man den sorgen machen
nein also der tötet man dann doch noch
fertig aber es sind hat es wird ein
hartes battle bereitschaft gibt gibt gut
elia hat es bamberg ad hoc vom schwein
oder ist in ihr kämpft aber ich muss
meinen sie verzaubern ja jetzt nächster
tipi zum verzaubert immer auf level 1
verzaubern wie immer immer immer warum
ist es gut wenn jetzt zum beispiel ein
schwert auf level 6 also verzaubert dann
kriegt ihr entweder schaffen es 112 gibt
es irgendwie erst ab einer relativ hohen
level zahl kriegt ihr also kriegt die
entweder schaffen s1 oder ihr kriegt
halt irgendwie smart oder patrol pops
oder so einen scheiß wie das ding heißt
und also immer level 1 dann kriegt ihr
mit der größten wahrscheinlichkeit
schadens 1 und ihr habt dann halt euro
weiteren level auch noch ihr aufhören so
zu sagen und könnt halt ja die ganzen
level auf wichtigere sachen anwenden wie
zum beispiel euren bogen zu verzaubern
ja gut den tipp mit seiner kraft name
schon gebracht die switches oder ob
schon gesagt ja auch noch ganz ganz ganz
wichtig leute am anfang wenn ihr kräfte
timmer helme und bot zuerst bestimmt ja
warum ich das gut der action zu sagen
und zwar der helm es gibt ja das so
genannte art steht und das gibt es hier
glaube ich ein startpaket das kann jeder
nehmen weiß zumindest ja genau und wenn
dieses checkit bogen habt und euch auf
einen headshot gibt
dann seid ihr direkt tot egal wieviel
rüstung gesamten habt so lange können
wir uns sagt die direktorin dass das
richtige ärgerlich wenn man eigentlich
eine ganz gute runde hat bevor du hast
jetzt schon india brustpanzer und da
wirst du einfach erschöpft von dem typen
der sonst nichts hat dass wir richtig
ärgerlich und die schuhe sind dafür da
fasst man es gibt ja so eine taktik die
nennt sich dauern
die wird mit vorliebe von pussys
ausgeführt und das heißt sie bauen sich
ganz viel holz ab und stecken sich dann
die luft so dass man wenn man getauscht
wird runterfällt
und wenn man dann in der luft liegt also
shift drückt dann kriegt man maximal
fünf herzen fall schaden wenn man schuhe
anhat also egal aus welcher höhe das ist
der trick als ein harter kampf gegen
elia ich finde ich bin ja es gibt noch
einen dritten
ja ich weiß gar nicht ob ich mich da
jetzt stellen sollte der ist es
offiziell er wirft einfach hat den
switch hochgeworfen bin ich aus dann
dabei will dass du kommst alles läuft
wieder hochladen
wo es runter gefallen aber es auf der
hand dass das budget also halt die von
tieren fern ich hab einfach gar keine
teile mehr alte scheiße das alleine auf
ja klar aber dahin dass der nächste denn
wirklich die beiden aufeinander was auch
da sind tiere haltlos von tieren für
manager sccm ich muss weg ok eine lücke
die mhh dreckige lügen alter wie heu
sich kaum anliegen bitte alter schwede
was für ein räudiger lügner dadurch die
krass richtiger chorleiter aber ganz
krass versagt ich werde mich nicht denn
in zweiter
jetzt kannst du
okay okay sie auf der hauptmann den
kürzesten hatte der wurde weggepustet
okay leute wenn man runterfällt
schnieken ganz wichtig immer ein wasser
höher mitführen für wasser fallen und
lava fallen und das war vielfalt die
besten aller zeiten
und ja leute falls ihr noch irgendwelche
tipps habt ihr mit dem man dieses
tutorial ergänzen könnte schreibt in die
kommentare
damit die anderen abonnenten und
zuschauer das mitbekommen dann würde ich
sagen macht's gut deute haut rein und
schau die ab